[Music]
Roman Empire reference holy [__] it's
true which era of the Roman Empire do
you want to discuss wait wait wait wait
that that was another thing that I did
on the long run is I looked up a Roman
Empire podcast cuz I was like I don't I
don't think about this enough yeah cuz I
don't know about it yeah I find one so
if you got a good one have you listen to
Hardcore History I haven't with Dan
Carlin yeah no I haven't but nether
I've I've watched a couple like you know
overviews of the Roman Empire and it
basically seems like it's
this the start of Rome it's like a myth
obviously about like two guys and a
dog Romulus and Remis I think okay
and they were like an in appar
supposedly Rome was like an in between
Village between like Greece and the
atrans and Rome was a place where people
who were not I I guess like prisoners
and criminals could like go start a new
life in Rome they could be granted a
form of citizenship that they would not
obtain like if like in Greece or okay
you know where the at truskin were SK I
guess and then over time this you know
obviously there's many many events
happened but by the time Rome became
like its own like I guess civilization
there's like periods where they had like
kings they had like seven Kings and then
they switched to the Republic and then
after the Republic there Rome got so
large that it was split into like
different country like factions and so
some people would make the argument that
the Roman Empire technically has never
fallen apart it's just been like minced
into different pieces over time so the
and the period that the Roman Empire
that I think people reference in their
mind is like Gladiators and [__] right
yeah so I think that's like
a 200 year or 500 year period I can't
remember the big thing with Rome was
when they conquered somewhere whatever
City they conquered or a like region
they would
basically promise like protection or
like they you know they would grant them
the ability to continue existing in
exchange for their firstborn sons and
stuff so Rome uh that's how it was able
to develop such like a massive military
through why do people think about it so
much uh are we being uh are we being for
for serious or we we joshing I mean I
think I know I think I know why because
it I feel like it's more interesting
than than that right what the Roman
Empire oh yeah no the the expansiveness
of it is really it's if you like Game of
Thrones yeah you cannot [__] on think
wanting to know about the Roman Empire
that that is that on steroids you know
like the story of Nero is pretty insane
everyone knows that you know I don't
Nero is like a I know anything do You
Nero Nero's a DJ yeah he's a he was like
a I know that well that's l that's late
stage capitalism for you it's kind of
insane how capitalism just tends to
cannibalize all that it from history
it's just it keeps re presenting the
same ideas or taking things and ruining
what's sacred and you know appropriating
them for products that that's a good
like pre-drop
thanks
yeah
UMO is known as one of Rome's most
infamous rulers notorious for his
cruelty and debauchery let's go he
ascended to power in ad 54 aged just 16
so he's like Jaw free yeah he died at 30
he had a good run the highlights for
Nero was
that his
mother
murdered the king to get Nero instated I
see and
then Nero later murdered his mother oh
oh yeah no sorry he didn't have his mom
killed he yeah he killed his wife and
then his second wife his name is Nero
Claudius Caesar Augustus germanicus yeah
but damn it that's what I was going to
name my son a when they restructured the
Roman Empire because of its size and
like they wanted to change how it was
run I forget who was in power but he
titled himself the Dominus the Dominus
which was like a word for apparently
like a slave owner okay like like the
master I'm like that's a intense name
yeah it really is holy [__] yeah it's
like the name and then the Dominus yeah
just like [__] that's what
uh that's what uh you
know the woman called the college guy no
that's what I that's what I have uh
goddess I have her named the Dominus in
my pH the Dominus yes goddess kick my
balls godd girl kick me in the nuts yeah
the girl kicks me in the nuts I call her
the Dominus yeah I got to get more into
history man history is interesting it's
really interesting m so I was looking up
hardcore history cuz I was like I know
everyone freaks out about the show and I
I'm going on these [__] super long
runs now I need something I can really
stick my teeth into think you know so
that when another meme comes along about
some age of History yeah I can be like
oh yeah I get it yeah so I searched you
know Dan Carlin's hardcore history and I
realized there was only like 12 it's the
show is so famous MH he only keeps the
most recent like 10 episodes up the rest
them you have to buy as a box set on his
website that's crazy so if you want to
buy episodes 1 through 50 or something
like that it's
$72 that's cool $79 one through 55
that's cool but I want to do it you you
should yeah think I'm going to do it
because I think the first one is about
Germany and Hitler and stuff like that
and then I'll probably do it after
this yeah there's a I was looking at one
of those Iceberg memes I was like
talking about how like the Roman Empire
is the top and the bottom is Niche
countries that don't exist
anymore yeah dude I mean that I
think that to me on tour was the I think
that's the part it's such a you know
that wo dude meme from way back yeah you
know that guy was all yeah but that
would [__] me me up repeatedly just just
going around Europe and laughing at
myself like dude I am what am I even in
this like the scope of this place
existing this is I should just leave I
should cancel my show and leave I'm an
idiot what am I even doing here yeah
just thinking about the long histories
of these places and then I come there to
be
like penis I got a big dick for a
spider you know and so uh yeah but yeah
history's cool is so what uh Have you
listened to any episodes of Dan Carlin
or no I started listening to One
couldn't really get into it I was like I
think I have to start from number one
from number one yeah is that all he's
famous for Dan Carlin or was he a
comedian or something I thought he was a
comic or is that George Carlin there's
George Carlin yeah but is Dan are we
thinking of that or is Dan I thought
Carlin was a comic and a history dude
but I never looked into it um but there
was a meme I
think I've seen this it's like you
either get into like you're he's a radio
host okay yeah when you're in your 30s
you like either get really into history
or you get
into I don't know being an alcoholic or
something yeah yeah but I felt the draw
I was like you know listening to these
podcast I was like [__] I feel like I
really want to get into this yeah I want
to learn more I'm just going to start at
the the very beginning yeah just year
one yeah you know what what were we
doing what were we up to I want to know
everything